renaud muselier merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous nous accueillir ici dans votre
ville de coeur marseille dans votre
région provence sud sud provence alpes
côte d'azur dont vous êtes évidemment le
président vous êtes également président
de région de france on est ensemble
pendant une heure pour cette interview
en partenariat avec la provence nice
matin et var matin et à mes côtés pour
cette interview qu'il aime les cas
vivent aujourd'hui les genres les
directeurs de rédaction de la provence
et denis carot bonjour denis bonjour
organe directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin première question de
museler belin payant était à votre place
il y à quelques minutes comment ça se
passe avec le nouveau maire de marseille
plutôt bien loggia sont mon principe est
assez simple à partir du moment où il ya
des élus qui sont légitimement élu par
un système démocratique sont les
interlocuteurs et dans lé cadre de nos
compétences nous devons chacun faire ce
que nous allons faire dans nos
compétences et en ce qui concerne les
compétences attribuées les régions qui
sont le transport les lycées l'économie
l'aménagement du territoire le plan de
relance je travaille la totalité des
maires en harmonie et je n'ai aucun
problème monsieur payant au contraire
comme sérieux vous l'avez souligné ma
ville de coeur mais c'est ma ville de
naissance cgem marseille comme tous les
marseillais gagnent leur vie de lier
donc a pas de spécificité parce qu'on
est élu on n'aime plus la ville que les
autres mais la réalité c'est que c'est
une ville capitale c'est la deuxième
ville de france et de vivre qu'à des
difficultés qui a des atouts et j'essaie
de faire en sorte que les compétences de
la région en équité avec le reste du
territoire régional soit face on sent
que la ville de marseille soit bien
traité et et puissent être opérationnels
dans les différents domaines qui sont
qui dépend de la région évidemment
commencé en parlant de la crise
sanitaire liée avec denis renaud
muselier
dans la région les alpes-maritimes ont
été concernés depuis le 27 février par
leur confinement
le week-end donc bien avant le reste de
la france or la rs a annoncé hier un
record de hospitalisation en soins
critiques dans la région ça veut dire
que la situation sanitaire ne s'améliore
pas ce qui ce qui touche les alpes
maritimes devrait servir de leçon est de
la france dans ce qui concerne les
prévisions épidémiologique depuis le
début vous l'avez souligner votre
reportage chez je suis assez critique
vis-à-vis de la gestion des crises
sanitaires
deuxième volet puisque en employant des
régions de france j'avais demandé à mes
collègues présidents de région de ne pas
faire polémique est donc dire que
pratiquement tout en septembre dès 2020
vous n'avez jamais entendu région
critiqué la gestion de la crise
sanitaire parce que quand on ne sait pas
que ça a évolué que c'est compliqué on a
tous eu des responsabilités importantes
on sait que c'est difficile donc il faut
être très calme
enfin on apprend comme dans la prise on
apprendra les difficultés et on a eu
pendant toute cette période de l'année
2020 tout ce que j'appelle le bazar des
critères donc on ne savait plus très
bien comment pendant la température du
pays par rapport à la pathologie donc
est ce qu on confinait au niveau
municipal territoriale et nationale
sur quels critères ce dont on est sûr
maintenant sûr c'est qu'il ya trois
critères qui doit être fondamentaux plus
un niveau de mesures dans les trois
critères vous avez le taux d'incidence
le taux d'incidence il doit pas dépasser
250 voilà il est fourni aujourd'hui dans
votre région et là est à 500 salariés en
moyenne sur la région on est passé à 6
ans
bouches-du-rhône et les alpes-maritimes
il était à 7 cents et il tâte accent et
plafonne à 400 points le taux de
positivité de thau positivité ça veut
dire quoi c'est un peu plus de 17 ans
d'âge et en dessous ou contaminées - en
novembre nous étions à 19 par exemple et
après vous avez le tout passé en
réanimation au dessus de 80 ya danger et
on ce retour est aujourd'hui dans la
région nous sommes avec un taux de
positivité de 8 donc ça c'est bien
et avec un taux de réanimation à 120 à
peu près en moyenne et des
alpes-maritimes de servir de leçon pour
la gestion nationale du progrès vous
étiez à 713 actions estime vous étiez à
700 avec 140 % de patients en
réanimation avec un taux d'incidence de
11 6 semaines après vous avez été les
premiers à avoir un confident assez
stricte et sévère quand même puisque
même je dis même pas aux 10 kilomètres
alors aujourd'hui on a et ainsi semaine
à près de 700 on est passé à 400 c'est
très significatif à l'amélioration de
140% patients l'animation mais passer à
mais on est à 400 bouge plus six
semaines après ça veut dire qu'il faut
être observateur que leur est prudent
sur les l'hypothèse d'une sortie du
confinement exactement est très prudent
et en même temps on voit bien la
capacité de rebond immédiat c'est que
par exemple dans les bouches du rhône
je pense qu'on a rebondit immédiatement
nous après le carnaval vous savez où
tout le monde est sorti
donc on a fait un forme de deux
gros kloster quoi on est depuis on n'a
fait que monter on est passé à 6 ans et
on a flambé depuis donc je finis excusez
moi j'étais un peu lent pour la prise de
position qui est de dire dans six
semaines on sera tranquille au niveau
national j'émets des réserves de grandes
réserves non pas parce que je suis un
scientifique épidémiologiste au médecin
l'ancien médecin du samu c'est que j'ai
simplement l'habitude de regarder ce qui
se passe ailleurs et qu'on regarde ce
qui se passe chez nous dans les
alpes-maritimes
on réalise qu'on ait un plateau très
haut et donc mais un mot si on pousse
votre raisonnement renaud muselier vous
nous dites ça plafonne dans les alpes
maritimes il faut servir d'exemple des
as tu méritais salvia est ce qu'il faut
aller
on parle pas de sortie de crise est ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin dans les
mesures coercitives
est-ce qu'il faut encore serrer la vis
pour faire redescendre ce tour il faut
surtout être cohérent dans les mesures
qui sont prises on ne peut pas changer
sans arrêt en permanence changer des
modalités définition de liberté de
circulation non c'est à dire que c'est
ce que je disais sur le bazar des
critères encore dans les années cela
vous dit ça suffit pas les mesures
coercitives on le voit ça de la femme
dans les âges le malade ça suffit pas
jeudi que le président de la république
nous a expliqué que le 26 avril on
pouvait glisser le 3 mai les lycées le
26 avril les écoles et que mimi on
ouvrirait nos terrasses mais quand je
regarde l'expérience des maritimes c'est
parce que c'est un pari très risqué
voilà dans ce paris là je suis parce que
ce pari très risqué et donc il faut
toujours donner une perspective à son
patient sont malades et aujourd'hui
notre pays est malade et donc il faut
toujours donner une perspective mais
cette perspective est là compte tenu de
l'expérience des alpes-maritimes qui ont
été très rigoureux dont très très
respectueux ils ont été très sérieux il
faisait beau plus donc ils ont bien
travaillé et l'expérience montre en tout
cas mais il ya cette différence c'est
que là il ya eu des écoles fermées en
plus les écoles ayant été faite non pas
pour gêner les enfants c'est surtout
pour empêcher les parents de sortir on
va revenir vous avez fait un truc qui a
beaucoup fait parler de lui en parle de
ce carnaval de la plaine 6500 personnes
qui ont défilé sans masque sans gestes
barrière à marseille ici à quelques
semaines et une semaine après vous avez
fait un tweet pour dire ben voilà on
voit les faits et vous vous basez sur
les cartes des marins-pompiers qui
montrait le taux de virus dans les eaux
usées de la ville ce qui représente au
final le taux de circulation
vous avez vraiment constaté ou une
hausse l'iace carnaval où l'on installé
depuis le mois de novembre sur la base
des expériences des marins pompiers une
une cartographie régionale
donc j'ai tous les étés territoire
métropolitain métropolitain et
territoriaux et je paye ça c'est la
région qui paie on allait aux tables à
leur tendance leveaux plus tout parce
que là avignon et on a les trois
métropoles père et nice toulon marseille
et où vous savez vous l'avez souligné
mais je soutiens le rappeler on a ça
depuis le nord et on n'a donc c'est ce
qui se passe une semaine après à peine
cinq jours exactement et dans les os
brisés vous avez trois critères qui sont
assez facilement par quartier vert jaune
orange et rouge
bon quand vous êtes en vert le jaune ou
jaune orange sur la brouille quand vous
êtes orange et rouge ça va mais là c'est
très simple dans la sphère des modes et
du carna là on a vu semaine d'après pour
une touche passé en orange
mais benoît tailleur à votre place il
nous disait c'est pas vrai il n'y a pas
de preuves il n'y a pas de preuves pour
montrer que ce carnaval de la plaine a
eu des incidences sur le terrain
sanitaires de la ville de marseille je
vous parlerai dans une histoire
politique parce que je constatais ils
disent ce qu'ils disent assez s'ils font
de la politique
ben oui mais enfin mais c'est surtout
ses amis donc il a du mal à condamner
ses amis donc c'est cette baie donc
serrée entre eux n'est pas mais moi je
rentre pas là dedans je fais simplement
un constat simple nous sommes en vert et
jaune il ya le festival de la peine la
semaine d'après on est jeunes orange l'a
terminée donc après là dedans on le fait
si je pense qu'il ya aussi quelque chose
je tiens à souligner ça on a tous envie
de faire la fête
on a tous envie d'aller dans les
restaurants dans les bars boire un café
sur une terrasse quand même assez sale
histoire qui nous qui nous importe est
donc aujourd'hui on a tous besoin mais
je pense que surtout dans les mesures
coercitives dont vous parlez est quelque
chose qui doit être ne faut pas changer
en permanence de deux critères mais à
quelque chose qui est très important il
faut que les organisateurs ou ce qu'ils
font en collectifs soient sévèrement
punis
le restaurateur qui fait des restaurants
primés
il doit plus avoir les autres les aides
de l'état il doit plus être accompagnés
et il doit avoir une verbalisation
massive il en va de même pour les gros
groupes mais il faut pas verbalisés en
permanence promet cas pas le masque ou
geldof la voiture et qui descend dans
votre région déçu récemment dans la
région il y en a dans toutes les régions
de france
je ne pense pas spécifique à six essais
par nexter qui a le rideau les fondeurs
mais cela s'ils sont pris attention il
faut qu'ils perdent tous des aides
parce que c'est pas normal que tous ceux
qui font les efforts et qui est qui et
qui souffre et qui le font avec dans
dignité très énorme souffrance soient
pénalisés et que ne puisse pas réouvrir
à cause de quelques tricheurs dans la
réflexion sur la crise dans
les choix concernant les mesures
sanitaires est ce que les élus locaux
sont écoutés et entendus sur le plan moi
j'ai toujours l'habitude de cette saison
c'est assez simple depuis le début on a
une crise sanitaire qui a entraîné une
crise économique qui entraîne une crise
sociale dans cette crise sanitaire
depuis début nous n'avons aucun écart
aucune écoute aucun contact autour de
travail aucun rapprochement avec mis sa
santé
depuis le début la méthode continue
depuis le début pour autant d'essayer en
permanence de de faire des propositions
comme nous l'avons fait sur les vaccins
comme nous l'ont fait sur les
vaccinodromes comme nous l'avons fait
sur les tests comme nous l'avons fait
sur les axes et les les se servir des
élus pour les vaccinodromes chaque fois
c'est non mais finalement ça devient oui
trois quatre cinq mois après en fonction
des dossiers mais qu'est ce qui est
nouveau c'est la proche du gouvernement
c'est les personnalités et
particulièrement non je ne fais pas une
histoire personnelle et monsieur virant
c'est le monsieur virant j'ai déjà dis
donc c'est passé ce après c'est
désagréable mais succès porte parole de
son ministère
je pense qu'on est dans un système qui
est très centralisé et je pense que
c'est d'autant plus compliqué pour le
gouvernement que monsieur le directeur
la santé mais ce salomon avec de conseil
scientifique à la veille de tous les
conseils de défense font un petit papier
au président de la république au premier
ministre au nombre de conseils des
différences alors disant écoutez si vous
faites pas ça vous allait entraîner la
mort de centaines de milliers de
personnes à terme et dans le terrain et
donc moi je voulais écrire et donc comme
ça je serai dégagé de tout de suite
pénale
et quand vous avez une pression comme ça
là dedans ça pose d'énormes difficultés
pour décideurs et en aval l'an passé
en maintenant et en aval ils veulent
tous concentrés c'est à dire que ils ne
sont pas capable de s'appuyer sur me
serre la défense de l'intérieur pour
gagner les cellules de crise ce qui
comme son métier et ne veulent pas
s'appuyer sur me serre la défense pour
la logistique
alors on se retrouve avec des débits des
problèmes de dysfonctionnement mécanique
entre les élus locaux les
sapeurs-pompiers les marins pompiers
l'organisation territoriale période de
crise et d énormes difficultés en terme
de logistique c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile parce que c'est pas des
logisticiens jeu que je compte du
contraire le ministre de la santé alors
que le mr est de chance il dit le
gouvernement se trompe dans sa stratégie
non je vais te dis pas ça je dis que le
gouvernement est sous pression de
quelques idées de gens qui les menacent
d'aller au pénal pas vraiment à ça il
centralise le ministre de la santé
centralise seconde action de façon à ne
pas partager
il ya un problème de transversalité
administratif et donc je répondais à la
question par apposer le logo parce que
c'est acquis son papa aux locaux nous ça
s'est toujours très mal passé quand même
monsieur monsieur
les rangs est venu ici à marseille pour
nous expliquer on nous ferme et pour des
raisons incroyable parce qu'on n'avait
absolument rien à voir avec les autres
critères sanitaires français donc on
n'était pas différente d'autres non il
nous a expliqué qu'il avait fait en
toute concertation alors qu'il nous a
dix 10 minutes avant je vous ferme
c'est pour moi c'est pas vraiment une
concertation parallèlement à ça dans
l'histoire des alpes-maritimes on a pu
voir deux cas très différents
l'appareil les locaux et on a une
territorialisation accepté difficilement
par les élus mais validé dans le cadre
de l'organisation avec le littoral et le
reste des places
il ya une territorialisation dans la
différenciation quand même là ça s'est
fait avec les élus locaux et ça a été
plutôt fait en harmonie et même si c'est
difficile ça a été accepté le coude
après ça a été à voir et merci tout en
dehors sans qu'on nous prévienne en quoi
que ce soit et donc cette méthode là eux
mêmes n'ont pas su s'adapter ou changer
voilà c'est ce que je regrette
oui alors par de vaccination justement
le gouvernement vont en ce moment une
accélération de la vaccination on voit
les efforts de communication qui sont
faits à des chiffres donnés tous les
jours il ya des petites infographie là
sur les réseaux sociaux du gouvernement
qui circulait ce que vous sur le terrain
vous constatez véritablement une
progression de cette vaccination est ce
que véritablement en accélère est-ce
qu'on a passé la vitesse supérieure en
la matière selon vous parce qu'on se
rend compte que c'est une attente de la
plupart des des provençaux aujourd'hui
on a une étape vous avez raison de le
souligner le démarrage a été
partiellement chaotique et je crois
[Musique]
critiquer et s'était largement mérité
pourquoi parce que souvenez vous quand
même que même le présent la république
en début d'année nous a dit ça parte pas
assez vite sa part pas assez fort il
faut servir des élus locaux sauf rd26 la
drôme
pendant que la culture du ministère la
santé c'est à dire surtout pas tout de
suite nous nous avons proposé avec les
régions de france avec les maires de
france servais et les départements
défense on a dit servez vous des croisés
et des pharmaciens qui sont capables de
faire les vaccinations pour les grippes
et qui font 15 millions de personnes en
et demi ils sont un endroit où vous avez
d'après la loi 4100 habitants autour
donnez leur les moyens ils ont des
logisticiens répartiteurs pour servir
les pharmacies allez-y avec les médecins
généralistes et en voiture impossible
donc il a fallu expliquer qu'il fallait
faire des centres centralisée puis
finalement dans la région de france est
reconnaissant à 103 bon mais il c'était
au début trompé en fait parce qu'ils
s'étaient trompés en clean de doses et
deux doses il avait élargi la population
pour la signer six cent mille personnes
et on en a deux la capacité qu'en faire
200 milles m'avait l'organisation camp
for 50 ml c'est ça qu'on a eu quand même
pas un mois et demi ici c'est ça pendant
ma vie maintenant
le premier ministre a pris les choses en
main je n'ai eu plusieurs fois au
téléphone
si j'arrive à échanger avec le premier
ministre il est très réceptif tokheim
écoute ce après cccc les contenus et
donc il a repris les choses en main on
est rentré dans les lacs synode de ron
s'est accéléré il y a bien entendu et je
ne pose pas de polémique là-dessus
d'ailleurs la livraison livraison elle
arrive elle arrive pas un petit à petit
ça arrive on rattrape notre retard et le
fait que maintenant ça soit plus sous
l'autorité du premier ministre qui
organise le dispositif pour qu'ils aient
le maximum de vaccination tout le temps
partout le plus possible change la
doctrine et donc ça commence à marcher
oui mais est-ce que les deux les arrive
parce que benoît vaillant le maire de
marseille il ya quelques minutes qu'il
nous disait j'ai eu des informations
hier soir de la rs je suis inquiet on va
avoir un problème dans l'arrivée des
doses et ça aura peut-être pour
conséquence de stopper les primo
vacciner au mois de mai est ce que vous
avez les mêmes informations est ce que
vous êtes sûrs et ses propos ça fera un
arrêt de la vaccination mois de mai nord
et primo vacciner c'est lui rappeler ce
qu'on va avoir des
est ok au moment où on doive déroulée et
que ça soit fluide ça soit facile
j'avais même proposé un moment mais
maintenant c'est trop tard de faire un
peu comme un incendie c'est à dire que
moi là où ça flambe comme ça entre les
alpes-maritimes
on n'est pas besoin de vacciner dans
d'autres parties de la france il n'y
avait pas de problème et il fallait que
quand il ya un incendie le canadair pour
éteindre un incendie
et là on vacciner à tout va toute la
population des alpes-maritimes pour
éradiquer la maladie pour pascal se
transmettent plutôt que d'aller vacciner
des gens n'ont osé thierry taux
d'incidence a cinq ans passés avec des
patients en réanimation à 10% fin ça n'a
aucun sens bon ben ça ça pas pu être
fait maintenant trop tard puisque
l'incendié a gagné le pays
donc le coût du canadair ne peut plus
fonctionner alors après aux médias oui
mais c'est pas gentil les gentils mais
je sais pas je suis pas gentil j'ai
c'est d'être efficace et pragmatique et
donc là aujourd'hui on a des doses qui
sont paris qui doivent arriver on a une
quantité de doses qui doit être validée
et ventilés et on nous explique au
dernier moment qu'il n'arrive pas c'est
un peu un problème de logistique avec
des ponts thermiques à un arrêt de la
campagne de l'ex de l'ex canari
robin est ce comme un robinet et robin
et vous vous dites que vous ouvrez
plaint pas d'eau puis d'un coup il nous
qui arrivent beaucoup dit vous avez peur
vous refermez mais c'est pas le bon
moment et donc vous avez un vrai
problème de robinetterie donc de
logistique de la distribution dans la
doc six nations alors que mais vous
savez c'est toujours la même histoire
ils avaient fait leurs calculs sur la
base d'un truc qui était assez simple
c'est de 30% des français va être
vaccinés donc comment fait-on pour aller
vacciner ceux qui veulent pas mais coûte
commence avec max idée d'être en pensant
déjà tu verras que ça viendra
aujourd'hui sont à 70% d'anticiper c'est
tout c'est ça que je reproche un peu
c'est mais ces clés des vaccinodromes a
aujourd'hui cinq mille personnes doivent
être vaccinées dans un seul centre à à
nice en revanche est ce que cette cette
concentration c'est vaccinodromes
ne sont pas ne nous nuisent pas quelque
part aux vaccinations dans
l'arrière-pays dans les zones rurales
comment ça s'organise j'avais bien
raison c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai mis en place un système de fair
play des vaccinaux bus donc j'ai pris
les bus de la région mais bisous l'a
fait circuler dans toute la région
j'ai fait j'en ai fait un par
département et chaque jour ils sont dans
des villages de moins de 2500 habitants
donc tous les jours ils sont et donc ils
ont un circuit avec le maire on a avec
la rx mis en place un circuit qui nous
permet au delà des vaccinodromes qui
sont en tirer dans les alpes-maritimes
beaucoup sur sur le littoral parce que
c'est les endroits où il y avait grand
nombre de populations aussi un grand
nombre de populations avec des maires
très déterminé très performant et
compétents christian david lisnard où le
maire du xive chacun où l'état bar où
chacun a son ascension au centre ils
sont très actifs très proactifs donc
appris à l'arrière pays dans les api a
mis en place dès l'accès aux bus et on a
un village tous les jours village de
moins de 2500 en indiquant de façon à ce
que c'est toujours pareil mais c'est que
du bon certes là où il ya beaucoup de
gens ont fait un accès aux drones
là vous avez des zones intermédiaires
vous mettez sur les pharmacies parce
qu'elle couvre et là vous n'avez pas de
pharmacie et souvent des fois des
déserts médicaux
vous faites venir mais l'accès par le
vaccin vaccinaux beef et donc pour -
vous allez vous amener le lac c'est en
tout près de la population
une question à renaud muselier docteur
en médecine on a vu toute cette
polémique autour du vaccin astrazeneca
et le risque potentiel
est ce que vous sentez vous devrez
défiance justement concernant ce vaccin
en particulier est ce que vous la
comprenez et est-ce qu'au final
d'ailleurs c'est pas un échec dans cette
politique de vaccination est ce que ça
va pas retarder
là encore le déploiement parce qu'il y
aura des inquiétudes sur les effets
secondaires des vaccins
il y a incontestablement un
un bug sur astrazeneca informe de buzz
en disant si vous prenez un phrasé des
cadres est tombé malade
c'est faux c'est faux une fois que c'est
parti
il faudrait soirée-là l'endiguer il faut
arriver à l'endiguer sur le plan
scientifique pour dire c'est faux mais
là vous êtes déjà en retard les sorties
des rames quelque sorte mais vous croyez
qu'on peut encore en sortiront peut
encore arriver cet arrêté d'essayer de
vouloir convaincre ceux qui veulent pas
piqué vacciner ce qu'ils veulent il ya
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui veulent être vaccinés voulait pas
vacciner mais vous n'êtes pas vacciné
vous voulez traction il venait on
vaccine il ya des centaines de milliers
de personnes qui adorent actionné au
manque de vaccins arrêtons de faire une
polémique inexistante
bon alors il ya ces gars qui veut dire
mais moi je veux que le falzar tu veux
te du kaiser vive la liberté
y en a pas il ya la phrase et dicature
pas c'est pas grave
toi tu veux te vacciner entre vaccine
voilà c c'est aussi simple que ça
si vous verrez ça fera comme au début au
début on nous expliquait il y en a que
30 % qui ne seraient actionnées
aujourd'hui 1 70% arrêtez de ne pas
renier 30% qui veulent pas et puis après
on va se retrouver dans un truc très
simple moi je veut nous couper dans les
chorégies d'orange les chorégies
d'orange elles dépendent de moi c'est
sûr le président les chorégies d'orange
temps plein air je fais mon protocole
sanitaire protocole sanitaire est très
simple c'est l'enfer comme un médecin
revenant à la médecine
vous êtes vacciné vous pouvez rentrer
vous n'êtes pas vacciné
vous avez réservé venez votre père votre
tête pcr vous n'avez pas votre test pcr
vous inquiétez pas vous aurez votre auto
test 10 buts après vous serez sur le
positif vous êtes comme ça vous rentrez
voulez pas ça vous rentrez pas c'est le
pragmatisme qui doit prévaloir selon
vous doit revenir à ses le bon sens
médical
on a oublié la bêtise on ne fait plus de
médecine on part du principe maintenant
que l'autre face aux malades ou pas
malade chez maxim tout le monde
et hop on va pouvoir s'en sortir oui non
mais c'est pas ça la médecine la
médecine c'est vous renforcez votre
immunologie donc vous prenez du zinc
l'aspect de la vitamine c d'un vitamine
d vous vous renforcez que vous faites
l'hiver
avant la grille tout simplement après
vous prenez les gestes barrière
indispensable vous faites attention pas
de plus de 6 ou laver les mains à
l'alcool sans arrêt vous avez un petit
problème pape oxymètre le petit doigt
dans aussi maintenant tout 97,26 l'est
pas ça vous évitera d'aller dans
l'animation
et puis quand même vous soigner vous
croyez que tous les médecins de france
aujourd'hui ils attendent simplement de
vous dire que vous êtes positif c'est
notre positive savez ce qu'il faut faire
ou ne suis pas très bien on va me dire
de rester chez moi ton espiègle
non non alors je ne prends pas dans
l'histoire du professeur en outre on
s'en sortira pas mais là c'est trop
missiles mais les anticoagulants
mais la corticothérapie est fonctionnel
marche si vous prenez la médecine maire
de soigner vos patients avant les
envoyer en réanimation
donc il faut peut-être commencer par ça
est ce que vous avez entendu qu'une
seule fois une seule fois depuis un an
et demi quelqu'un qui n'ont pas de soins
pour les médecins généralistes ce pays
on nous a toujours dit ne faites pas
s'il ne fait pas ça on est capable que
d'interdire de ce pays et moi j'aimerais
comment rappelle simplement que nous les
médecins et médecins généralistes ici au
bout vous avez 160 médecins qui soignent
des gens qui lisent mais voilà quels
sont les soins que j'apporte
immédiatement des patients quand ils
sont positifs
c'est ça qu'il faut faire pour prendre
la médecine par lavage redonner de la
place aux médecins généralistes ça vous
semble important à dans cette crise mais
ils sont premiers ils sont démunis en
première ligne et en plus sans les
contraintes en ligne en même temps peut
au final valoriser mis en avant jamais
ça jamais plus pauvres coffret aller de
la crise mais on est quand même qu'on
nous donne un petit protocole strict
petit prompte aux grandes médical nous
ont regardés mais sa santé l'a toujours
dit ce qu'il ne faut pas faire tours
il nous a pas dit regardez ce protocole
a en fonction des pathologies c'est
notre métier a fait dix ans d'études
on n'a pas gagné nos diplômes sur
internet donc en fonction de vos
pathologie en fonction ont fait en sorte
que donc on adapte de nos soins avec un
protocole de soin et de prévention
dernière question avant de parler de la
crise économique sur la crise interne
président en question près président de
région de france la crise à l'italie ce
que pour vous elle a montré que le
renforcement de la décentralisation
c'était une utopie à une loi cadre des
qui doit
iv a priori me mais est ce que vous
craignez 15 à la hauteur les quatre
décès dans le design 4e dé qui est
apparu à vous avez donc après je crois
que le cartel des ces différenciations
distance et complexifie la
complexification moi je mettrais plutôt
une déception
voila voila c'est assez décevant quand
ça nettoie une râpe orient pour vous je
m'entends bien et même bourreau on a
beaucoup travaillé ensemble là dessus en
amont
on était très très très partisan de
faire une vraie décentralisation il y
avait une vraie ambition derrière et ça
finit avec un peu d'eau tiède corps
vraiment donc s'appeler rifi deux trois
trucs voilà qu'est ce qu'il faut comme
transfert de compétences pour les
régions pour vous parler ap les
insanités à l'exemple des high res c'est
sa voix par exemple les agressent et
pour être piloté par les régions il faut
uniquement changer le pilotage où il
faut revoir totalement le fonctionnement
des ars elles sont aux ordres de l'état
dans la région provence alpes côte
d'azur monsieur de mme esther chemtai
reste un nombre remarquable moi je
m'entends très bien avec lui on
travaille la main dans la main quand il
avait zéro masque quand même 13 millions
sur la table nous la région provence
alpes côte d'azur
nous les régions de france entre 30
millions de masques les endroits où mes
collègues présidents de région il
n'arrivait pas à s'entendre ars parce
qu'ils sont eux sous les ordres de leur
ministère comme le mien d'ailleurs il
retombe jamais cessé le serviteur de
l'état
mais schumi lionel julie mais dites moi
vous voulez donnez vous en avez pas moi
je fournis derrière mes maîtresses
millions de masques j'allais chercher en
chine quand même j'ai signé sur mes
responsabilités personnelles
les commandes mais quand même là j'ai
pas l'état pour m'aider rien parce qu'il
fallait faire les marchés
mais heureusement j'ai un possible parce
que les marchés ne pas me faire piquer
mes masques sur le tarmac et j'ai fourni
13 millions de masques dans la région et
mon adresse en étaient dépourvus
heureusement je m'entendais bien avec
lui pour pouvoir faire en sorte que les
rats étaient fournis des policiers on a
organisé gentiment au service de rita
d'ailleurs au service de nos populations
une organisation sanitaire incroyable et
donc pourquoi on ne peut pas voir ça
toute l'année
sachant que c'est le central c'est le
national qui décident voilà et c'est
nous qui appliquons mais on est plus
efficace plus rapide plus souple on sent
mieux notés oui effectivement parce que
cette crise sanitaire a une autre
conséquence c'est une crise économique
majeure
ça forcément on le voit au quotidien
vous savez combien la crise a coûté
depuis un an dans la région sud
ça dépend des secteurs mais c'est
colossal
c'est colossal parce que vous avez eu la
période de la première période qui part
pour new mi février et qui arrive
jusqu'à mi mai à peu près dans les deux
mois et là on perd grosso modo 4 points
du pib régional
on a un rebond très très fort à partir
de l'été c'est en effet la tête dès la
fin des terrasses dans la région qui
avait très bien marché je me bats
toujours pour la vie
donc le retour à la vie c'est quelque
chose d'essentiel pour moi ça avait très
bien marché on a fait une très belle
saison d'été quand même donc on calme à
compenser après et après derrière on a
eu un mois de novembre catastrophique
et puis on a eu plein désastre
économique avec une épée et les sports
d'hiver dont gross donc et après ça
dépend des secteurs tous les secteurs
hôtelier bas restons tout nu mis en fait
un marc hôtels cafés restaurants etc
tourisme la scène désastre le nombre
d'entreprises déjà fermé des pertes du
secteur des secteurs ils ont perdu 95 %
de leur chiffre dans l'année quand même
mais sur l'ensemble de la région on peut
dire qu'on s'est appauvrie 15%
donc nous on est venu à la rescousse
avec l'état et je tiens à remercier je
travaille beaucoup et monsieur le maire
tout le aux entreprises dans des régions
de france
on était tous les lundis au téléphone
c'est que t'as pas secteur branche par
branche et il apporté de réponses ou
temps là ils ont été deux fois par jour
on a beaucoup critiqué merci là quand
même
ils ont été ils ont sauvé des filières
entières des pans entiers de notre
économie siens comme airbus hélicoptère
par exemple comme la cnim dans le marché
aussi s'il n'ya pas le plan de relance
au ciap à la démarche du ministère pour
sauver des fleurons industriels puis
après sauver des branches entières de
l'hôtellerie des branches entières de la
restauration la branche entière des
cafetiers chez nous alors p
j'ai le tourisme la culture et à plat
mais on va en parler avec de l'or
justement pour évoquer le tourisme qui
est une activité majeure dans la région
qui est extrêmement touché par par la
crise on l'a vu et vous l'évoquez aussi
il y a eu énormément de monde l'été
dernier la saison a été bonne comment
vous préparer l'été qui arrive
quel est l'enjeu il ya toujours
plusieurs volets dans cette histoire moi
j'essaie toujours mais des sombres
perspectives
on a un mois d'avril catastrophiques
puisqu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui j'ai
une action très spécifique pour trois
catégories y est ce que j'appelle les
chèques nounou pour les mamans ou les
papas qui ont des enfants sont en fait
les travailler donc il ya chaque mot new
de 200 euros qui se met en place pour le
mois d'avril pour être et d
accompagnement parallèlement à ça on
débloque des moyens financiers à hauteur
de 500 euros pour les commerces fermer
de façon à ce qu'il puisse payer leur
loyer c'est un chèque complémentaires et
puis à ce qu on oublie toujours excusez
moi mais et qui s'imposera fille ça
finira par poser problème ce qu'on
applaudissait tout le temps pour mes au
match aller là aujourd'hui plus personne
les applaudit ils sont toujours 140 %
avec une patte avait des difficultés et
donc on va faire un chèque vacances pour
tout le personnel de réanimation de 400
euros à consommer localement car ça
permet de ramasser après d'ailleurs ça
c'est ça c'est ça on peut partir du
principe que sir mais on est où il ya un
autre volet c'est à ce moment là on est
la terre des festivals ici et mon idée
et j'avais été des réunions avec les
différents syndicats du monde de la
culture est acheté avec le prodiss les
spectacles vivants pour faire en sorte
que au moins en respectant les gestes
barrières tout ce qui est plein air on
ouvre au moins ça et en or avec un
protocole sanitaire qu'ils ont mis en
place qui a été validé au niveau
national comme au niveau local que l'on
peut conforter nous ici assez facilement
plus dans lequel je vais des moyens pour
essayer de réunir sa part également ça
c'est sûr en tout cas moi je l'ouvrirai
l'écologie durant j'ai déjà dit mais
réservation et jeu et je mets en place
un protocole sanitaire qui fait en sorte
que l'on va avoir du mal à m'expliquer
que ça marche pas d'entretien c'est dans
le cadre de respect le respect stricte
n'a pas triché et non mais moi je suis
public celui public elle est privée et
là d'autres difficultés pour organiser à
céder ce comédien pour diriger tout le
volet des bars et terrasses mais pas les
terrasses il faut qu'ils avaient voilà
et bien et donc on a fait c'est par ici
marseille avec le restaurateur et 10 h
et on a fait quatre demandes de tests de
réouverture d'expérimentation à
l'intérieur des terres toujours refusées
même temps on peut essayer un peu aussi
bien organiser des spectacles et les
concernant avaient demandé comme
impartiale
le dogme c'est trois fois ça nous était
repoussée trois fois et c'est plus
d'actualité si on nous explique ça sera
pour le 19 mai bon autant vous dire
c'est que 40 des grecs donc donc on va
s'adapter et puis après j'organise
j'essaie d'organiser ces en sorte que ce
qu'ont expliqué que de toute façon sera
ouvert ce moment là je vais réouvrir me
terrasse à la fin des terrasses le 1er
juillet pour qu'on retrouve à la vie a
fait des terrasses et et qu'on respire
donc et qu'on va apprendre à vivre avec
comme n'importe quelle vie on apprend du
robec on fait attention
oui renommé the year vous vous avez
quelques attaches dans la vallée de
l'ubaye 1 je crois du côté du sauze
c'est un secteur touristique qui a été
fortement frappé les stations n'ont pas
pu ouvrir les stations des alpes du sud
cette année c'est un secteur qui est
très impacté
est ce qu'on a fait assez pour aider ce
secteur-là qui englobe plusieurs choses
il ya bien sûr tous les professionnels
de la neige mais également tous les les
tous les commerces inhérents j'allais
dire à ceux à ce secteur là est ce qu'on
a fait assez et est-ce qu'il va falloir
réinventer ce modèle de la station de
ski est ce qu'il va voir une souffrance
réelle pour la saison prochaine si elles
peuvent rouvrir
alors je vais essayer d'être très rapide
on nous a expliqué qu'il fallait faire
mais noël même 5% du chiffre d'affaires
pour être sûr d'ouvrir on naviguera en
fin février donc voilà le creux est donc
le fight un choc
il a eu un fils il a fait 12 protocole
sanitaire pour les perches à l'extérieur
extrêmement comme il y avait quand même
une tempête forte la totalité des
professionnels dans lequel il y avait
aussi les présidents de région
d'ailleurs
les moyens financière est énorme et donc
de l'état donc secteur c est parce qu en
fait faut grosso modo 25% du chiffre
mais ils ont font à peu près 25 pour ça
en février sont 60% pour les fêtes de
février fait janvier est donc là ils
sont trompés parce qu'en février il
voulait fermer janvier alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas contaminés
enfin ils ont fermé noël à un condé pas
contaminée pour sauver février dont ils
ont l'année entière était finie parce
qu'ils avaient fermé en mars avant
n'oublie pas ils ont fait une année
complète et donc comme il a bien engagé
des moyens financiers importants pour
noël mais ils ont mis les mêmes en
février donc ils ont qu'a eu des aides
massives mais les aides massives
ce n'est jamais que la perfusion pour
les travailleurs veulent travailler en
plus serrés d'amener cette année c'est
un désastre et puis c'est
incompréhensible fortement compenser la
décision sur le plan sanitaire et donc
j'ai un sentiment d'injustice là dessus
pour la suite nous on a mis la région on
a fait un plan avec la totalité des
professionnels de santé
l'année dernière la dernière fois on a
mis 50 millions pour les montagnes 50
millions pour les vallées est donc 100
millions on fait pour les espèces de
liens et là on en a mis 200 millions
pour le rentrer de façon à ce que l'on
réinvente l'organisation des stations
davantage quand même ce que la vente à
elle si je puis dire c'est tous ceux qui
sont contre la neige ils ont réalisé que
sans la neige on peut pas vivre le monde
est rien et que les stations de ski ça
fait vivre et ça ça fait vivre les
montagnes et que les stations de ski sa
lutte contre la désertification donc ou
moins le seul avantage dans ce désastre
ça a rappelé ça rappelait quand même
besoin de skier et que la neige était
quand même un or blanc autre sujet on
parle du froid eu un gros coup de gel
ces derniers jours dans de nombreuses
régions le gouvernement qui a décrété
hier le régime de calamité agricole
quelles conséquences a eu dans la région
sud
danse est un peu différente vaucluse est
très touchée puisque on est à vingt
portion de casse ça descend un peu après
sur arte 10% sur le haut des bouches du
rhône en est à 5 10% le va'a moins
touchées j'ai débloqué hier cinq cent
mille euros immédiatement je travaille
qu'avec les syndicats agricoles en
fallait les coopérations et les les
chamailleries du futur c'est et dans les
alpes on a on a une inquiétude sur les
vergers
voilà donc les vignerons ce bien bien
abîmé les vergers en plus en plus dans
tous vos clients n'allait les fraises
tous à ce moment là donc là il ya de la
casse un il ya beaucoup de casse dans
aucune et dans les alpes il y avait tout
le broyer les os des du bouches du rhône
et à le fold et des arbres enfin et qui
est l'abruti n'en suis inquiet oui oui
grosse inquiétude a parlé du ferroviaire
de la région sud a été la première à
lancer l'ouverture à la concurrence
l'appel d'offres est terminée quels sont
le quel est le calendrier quels sont les
objectifs dans le fond est-ce que c'est
d'abord l'amélioration du service est ce
que c'est
réaliser des économies vous savez que
j'ai un grand professionnel de l'europe
un peu à moi puisque j'étais
parlementaire européen à la commission
transports du parlement européen j'étais
classé des trois meilleurs députés
européens d'ailleurs dans la crise
sanitaire
là je viens de gagner le prix des six
meilleures régions d'europe
dans le cas de la gestion de la crise et
2020 est la seule française donc j'ai eu
un satisfecit européen tout j'ai pas
toujours au niveau local donc au moins
ça fait toujours plaisir à dire de
l'extérieur l'europe elle fonctionne au
niveau du train avec des ouvertures la
concurrence ça permet d'avoir de
meilleurs services
or nous nous avions ici largement
provence après d'ailleurs quand nous
sommes arrivés avec christian la plus
mauvaise régions de france il y avait 20
% de trains et qui était en permanence
en retard enfin dans quelque 80% à leurs
plumes les régions de france
vous avez
10 % de trains annulés allumez
complètement jamais un remboursement
donc on a attaqué la sncf on a fait
toutes sortes de choses on s'est mis
dans les règles européennes
un peu avant tout le monde et on est
aujourd'hui à 91% de régularité il en a
gagné 170 millions d'euros dans cette
histoire paraît sincère et donc quand on
avait un peu plus loin dans la démarche
dans les marchés indien times regard
fermé
pas une ligne ferme et censier tenue
diminution des coûts amélioration de la
qualité du service
on a acheter des rames on a sécurisé on
a mis la garde régional des trains c'est
un compte
sauf que et on a diminué l'abonnement
qui l abonnement sous le passage ou pour
les jeunes avec la prise 10 euros toute
la nuit vont ils veulent quand ils
veulent et donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec une amélioration des
services en améliorant du service de la
sncf a pu s'améliorer
donc allez la compétition donc elle
n'est pas sortie du jeu mais n'a jamais
été sortie du jeu parce que elle veut
pas sortir à la raison d'ailleurs
parce que si les autres rempl ll va se
retrouver en compétition par tour et
parce que mes collègues présidents de
région il regarde comment ça se passe
chez moi et je suis né à l'expérimental
en quelque sorte mais j'ai gagné en
régularité
je gagne en qualité j'ai gagné en
compétitivité et j'ai gagné en moyens
financiers très bien pour le pôle
clients pour le patient parce que sur le
voyageur pour sortir les voitures aussi
puisque le train et électriques
maintenant donc on se retrouve dans une
situation où la sncf s'est
considérablement améliorée et dans le
cas de la discussion
dans le cadre des dépôts qui ont été
faits on veut encore améliorer l'offre
parce qu'ils sont en compétition
alors justement les trains vous dites
ils sont électriques mais pas seulement
vous aviez évoqué l'idée qu'on développe
ici de façon d'un
peu expérimentale en étant les pionniers
des trains à hydrogène la fameuse
énergies du futur
visiblement il ya quatre régions qui ont
fait ce choix là qui vont expérimenter
nous pas encore c'est un choix là aussi
de reporter cette expérimentation
nous on a ciblé l'hydrogène pour les
entreprises on a regardé pour les trains
donc pour les entreprises vont engager
notre plage rouge n etc
c'est l'alimentation des entreprises
pour décharger en fuel etc
donc ça s'est élancée est organisée pour
le véhicule roulant c'est pas possible
sur les cartes de suite mais une flotte
sera renouvelée plus tard donc ça c'est
pour les bus et on a des bus hybrides
électriques et on aura des volets
d'hydrogène 2023 et sur les trains on a
une longue discussion là dessus c'est
que à quel endroit ils se ravitaillent
en fait il s'agit taille est en fête et
à quel moment ces pentes youn le fasse
et il ya un problème technique là dessus
et donc et à quel moment on renouvelle
notre flotte donc nous notre priorité
essentielle c'était sur les bouches du
rhône
c'était
aix-marseille puisqu'on n'a pas
d'explication d'homme mais un peu tard
batterie et la côte bleue est donc là on
entre en batterie il a dans un premier
temps là ses batteries ces faits ses
commandes et sarir batterie porte bleue
sur ces deux axes et sur l'autre ligne
qui va jusqu'à toulon batterie et après
d'hydrogène viendra sur marseille
briançon et sur les alpes maritimes qui
sont encore une autre
notre démarche on est en train de
travailler là sur l'énergie avec les
compétiteurs de l'appel à projets alors
justement de questions sur ferroviaire
pour me rapprocher de mon ami denis
anisi à cette ligne nouvelle toujours
dans les tuyaux entre marseille et nice
1 un petit peu plus d'une heure on en
rêve tous ça c'est un projet qui sera
réaliste réalisable jours si je veux
aller prendre l'apéro concours à lise
avec la pluie avec un petit prix avec
certains et vous pourrez discuter à une
autre compagne en espérant qu'on est
plus les masques on a
là aussi essentielle
on a traité ce dossier on a réussi à
l'avoir c'était philippe tabarot qui le
traitait à la région en tant que vice
président des transports est maintenant
et à la commission du transport au sénat
nous avons des tréteaux valider un bon
compte et au ministère des transports
c'est au lit maintenant on est le seul
dossier en france comme ça de ce niveau
mais il ya une cohérence on allait on a
les montagnes est derrière et on a la
maire de sceaux donc on peut va mettre
des autoroutes supplémentaires on a des
habitants qui sont là faut bien trouver
un moyen de circulation qui soit adaptée
plus tôt que ce que l'on a aujourd'hui
et donc c'est un vrai sens écologique
environnementale et d'avenir c'est comme
ça qu'il faut poser maintenant c'est à
quatre sous-commissions se retrouve dans
une gt yade le préfet de région on
travaille sur le contrat d'avenir
nous avons validé le fait que dans les
clés de répartition l'état ne sera qu'à
40% des collectivités seront 45% 45% et
le repas 10 pour ça donc on va voir si
on peut avoir une enveloppe
supplémentaire de l'europe
on va voir comment se répartissent à
entre collectivités pour financer ça on
va voir après autre volet il faut faire
une société de projet de façon à
regrouper tout le monde et qu'on n'est
pas des défaillances au fil de l'eau
société de projet qui nous permettra de
à ce moment-là d'organiser de coordonner
mais c'est en cours
c'est en cours de validation l'arbitrage
est en cours et ça avance
autre gros sujet pour votre région sont
les suites de la tempête alex qui a
dévasté les trois vallées des alpes
maritimes on a vu la mobilisation à tous
les niveaux à commencer par la
mobilisation des collectivités locales
l'état s'est engagé à fait des promesses
est ce que ces promesses sont tenues et
sont à la hauteur de l'enjeu et de cette
reconstruction qui va prendre des années
alors est ce que c'est à la hauteur il
en faut toujours plus est-ce que ça va à
la vitesse ça va jamais assez vite et on
alterne des mauvaises surprises
quand vous avez on pense qu'on va
pouvoir passer avec le rail on voit que
c'est les piliers du pont qui tiennent
pas et que le train passait alors que le
rail fonctionner mais bon on as qui
l'ont été à la hauteur
c'est comme la région qui a fourni des
dicos pour des anglais longe et la
vallée tout le temps quand même
donc j'ai pas vocation à être une
compagnie d'hélicoptères pour
désengorger les pauvres gens qui voient
dans la vallée donc est ce que je sais
c'est que le conseil départemental avec
monsieur ginésy la métropole avec
monsieur estrosi l'aide de tout le monde
avec monsieur ciotti le maire de montaut
monsieur guibal on
ils ont été là nous à la région on est
venu en soutien en apport même 50
millions quand même directement sur la
table on vient de remettre
on a discuté avec challenges inédits et
1 5 million on a débloqué avec l'europe
je suis allé chercher avec christian
estrosi des sous à l'europe pour fédérer
les différents pays européens dans
l'aide d'urgence pour récupérer 65
millions supplémentaires donc rien que
la région rien que la région et l'europe
puisqu'on a mobilisé tout ça on aura
misé 170 millions dans l'histoire en mai
ce que c'est suffisant pour ses ports
aux leurs quand on a vu là bas qui s'est
retrouvé un moment vous avez plus d'eau
plus d'électricité même plus de câble en
fin de de connexion internet
c'est et puis maintenant ils
reconstruisent alors je suis ça de très
près au quotidien mais élus de la vallée
aussi nous font remonter le train arrive
les routes sont refaites l'électricité
est là mais on a un sentiment de
dévastation plus quand on est là et donc
cesser ce sentiment là donc on fait le
maximum le plus tôt possible
est ce que l'état était à la hauteur
rien n'aurait pu le public est assez
longtemps moi je connais bien des prêts
on aurait pu y rester longtemps il était
en contact avec les gens
quand ils nous ont mis l'armée toujours
par ailleurs logistique ça a beaucoup
aidé quand même fort m'a fait gagner
beaucoup de tort quand ils nous enlèvent
l'armée après c'est là puisqu'il n'y en
a plus que l'autre est fixée en occuper
c'est un peu plus court quoi voilà on va
parler des régionales non ono muselier
auront tels lieux ont joint c'est la
question et c'est la question que pose
jean castex en ce moment pour vous ce
report il est inenvisageable
moi j'ai cité nature elle savait prudent
j'ai puis on voit bien que la crise
sanitaire il faut être prudent après je
fais de la politique je vais entendre
que les régions de france j'ai mis cette
prudence ils ont décidé de dire on va
voter
ok en fait il ya plusieurs volets il
reste que les candidats potentiels comme
nous départements et régions veulent
aller voter ils disent oui bon deuxième
truc
est-ce que la campagne peut être
organisé les partis disent oui ok et
après les maires disent est ce que vous
pouvez les organiser et l'association
des maires de france dit oui
est-ce que ça s'est fait dans d'autres
pays européens globalement tout le monde
a voté sauf les italiens qu'on est calé
non donc
ci après après je reviens sur le conseil
scientifique s'cusez moi j'ai encore
désert mais c'est terrible la décision
qui leur avis avant j'avais du
gouvernement ne mettez pas la clause de
revoyure
parce qu'à la clause de revoyure vous
allez vous retrouver dans un pataquès
album incroyable vous ne mettez pas
brison mis la clause de revoyure d'un
conseil scientifique
nous ne sommes pas les décideurs savent
et nous pas nous bon donc normalement un
scrutin doit être tenu pas donc ils
décideront mais pour que sa tenue il
faut tenir compte des sanitaires
et quand vous regardez la liste des
contraintes pour tenir les bureaux de
vote et là il ya deux élections et même
jour ça rend ça rend la décision
impossible parce que ça me paraît très
compliqué à organiser
mais bon mes collègues ont dit oui
allons-y
et si le président de la république a
raison quand il dit qu'on ouvre nos
terrasses ans mais je vois pas pourquoi
on n'aurait pas voté en juin
donc ça va encore on vote mais sur le
plan sanitaire c'est pas forcément la
meilleure solution c'est quoi c'est
vraiment la vie il faut faire et ne
revoyons de la revoyure donc il faut
aller chez un temps mais on va se dire
quand même est ce que est ce que si la
thèse et maritimes qui fait en sorte que
six semaines après on voit que ça n'a
pas évolué ou en un plateau très haut ça
veut dire que parmi mes enfants au bout
de sept huit semaines par rapport à
décision qui a été prise par le
président dont foraine revoyure à ce
moment là je pense qu'il y aura une
revoyons dollar voyons donc si on n'est
pas sûr que les élections se tiennent en
juin je pense que le gouvernement va
voter et je suis pas parlementaire je
pense que dès cette semaine
débat au parlement et je pense que le
gouvernement demandera l'avis des
parlementaires et les parlementaires
côté sénat comme côté a semblé dire on
va voter mais vous la position c'est
votre position personnelle la valeur de
l'art et voyeur ou c'est une position
qui sera partagée par régions de france
c'est une position qui sera partagée par
territoire unis est signée aussi avec le
président national territoire union
rappel c'est le rassemblement des
régions des départements et des mains
renaud muselier la commission nationale
d'investiture des républicains s'est
réuni mercredi elle vous a apporté le
soutien du parti ça veut dire qu'on a en
face de nous un candidat aux régionales
dont c'est un président de région qui a
un qui à la manoeuvre depuis un an et
demi qui ceux qui se lèvent la peau mais
il ya un calendrier qui courent de sable
dans ce calendrier qui courent
j'appartiens à une famille politique et
l'air je respecte les statuts de ma
famille politique et donc à une
commission d'investiture je me suis
présenté avec les responsables
politiques régionaux parlementaires
présidents de départements ou ou
secrétaires départementaux pour dire que
je n'étais pas candidat mais que je
demande le soutien de mon parti et à
l'unanimité je le soutiens mon parti en
n'étant pas candidat à l'un des
meilleurs c'est bizarre ça secret de
polichinelle ces noms c'est un garçon
raisonnable voilà j'aime ce que je fais
je j'y consacre beaucoup de mon temps je
suis très inquiet de beaucoup de choses
je trouve qu'on ne parle jamais des
jeunes va jamais des étudiants jamais
des études des étudiants jamais jamais
on leur propose jamais rien en termes de
vaccination rien donc j'ai passé un a
fait quelque chose qui pourrait faire
que vous ne soyez pas candidat la
maladie déjà et le sentiment d'avoir mal
fait et peut-être le fait que
avec tout ce que j'ai fait et si les
gens me soutiennent pas c'est
désespérant je peux faire autre chose
donc je suis très vivre je citerai livre
je ne veux pas du front national bien
entendu mais je veux la réouverture
quand je veux la réouverture de mes
barres de mes restaurants les cafés de
vivre je vivre je me bats pour la vie
donc je suis respectueux de mes instants
sportif de sierre
voilà j'ai toujours été là je passais
donc voilà mais chez un garçon ouvert à
tous est ouvert j'essaie de trouver les
solutions et les meilleurs et plus fort
le plus compétent et plus performant ce
qui ce qui me met pas des bâtons dans la
vo toute la journée vous le savez
monsieur à quel point moi j'étais gêné
handicapées est coincé par la propre
famille dans mes propres rangs pour pour
essayer de m'épanouir au service de
l'intérêt général
maintenant j'ai la capacité de faire
c'est tout ce que j'ai fait on me dit
pas bien compte après tout alors c'est
pas un état mais finalement chez un
médecin généraliste ou chez un médecin
interniste ou chez un médecin du samu où
j'ai peut-être bien fait regarder même
les européens ne disent pas si cela si
les gens me disaient vas-y on a besoin
d'ouverture
muselier mais jusqu'à quel point vous
allez dire vous avez envie de faire
preuve d'ouverture
je pense à christophe castaner qui avait
été candidat face à christian estrosi
lors du précédent scrutin et qui du coup
la lance des appels du pied pour dire
partons ensemble avec la liste de renaud
muselier
il vous tend la main et plus que ça
comment vous voyez les choses est ce que
il y aura pas de rapprochement avant le
premier tour partira ensemble il y aura
je veux pas d'accord l'appareil vous
savez que j'ai très bonnes relations
entre les circassiens depuis toujours
même quand il était candidat contre nous
cet artisan du de son départ j'ai
contribué
quand il était ministre de l'intérieur
j'avais fait la cagnotte aux profils et
des policiers qui avaient été frappés
j'ai vu personne mais dès le gtc au
matin dit que c'était bien que ce thème
à ce que je faisais je les réussis
d'ailleurs ces camions et demi quand
même pour les pauvres policiers qui
avaient été frappés pompiers ou
gendarmes je crois que c'était plutôt de
cagnotte face à l'autre cagnotte pour ça
je l'avais fait que de 50000 euros pour
défendre le frappeur quand même un nom
est d'ailleurs celui qui l'a l'organiser
partis et des sous bon ça me redonne la
mentalité et j'avais plus de 5 après une
personne
donc moi je suis pour l'autorité je suis
je suis pour les gens intelligents qui
sont capables de travailler ensemble il
me tend la main christophe castaner je
lui ai dit avec un peu de malice savez
que j'aime bien qu'il a fait un peu
d'humour
on est en pertes de convives personnes
et serre la main on fait un test pcr
pour voir un peu pcr c'est le programme
c'est quoi votre programme
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est les
compétences et avec compétence ya le
sait de confiance aussi quand même parce
que dans ce monde si on peut établir un
peu de confiance et pas mal les
compétences et après vous avez la
république parce que c'est ya le front
est il donc l'extrême droite et et vous
avez la région et si on est positive 1 g
par et pour mon pc j'ai pas a répondu de
pc dans la seconde je vais arriver à
ministre déboulé inconnu dit navidad en
être candidat je sais pas une bonne
méthode de figure quand même pour le
pour le pour le pour le pcr s'est pas de
pc je rentre chez toi et puis j'étais
d'expliquer que subit la côtoient
peut-être peut-être
et comme envers interpréter ce donc que
cette candidature de sophie cluzel qui
est membre du gouvernement et qui jette
un peu de ça comme ils ont fait un peu à
marseille c'est à dire que à l'intérieur
des dents marche c'est très particulier
vous avez un tiers de gens qui nous
aiment bien
nous les mecs de droite qu'ils avaient
un tiers de mai qui nous aiment pas
parce que c'est des gens issus de la
gauche qui est en train d opportuniste
qui essaie de se placer en font que vous
discutez avec un des deux autres tiers
les deux entretiens ont fait naître
entre vous toujours toujours toujours et
donc vous retrouver dans une situation
où vous n'avez contrairement à nos
formations politiques pas
d'interlocuteur réel cléa et crédible il
change d'avis sans arrêt en fait donc
partie changea ville sans arrêt vous
pourrez diction discuter ça c'est pour
la discussion commune faisons
classiquement enfin moi j'ai les armes
et modem qui en sont tous avec moi ils
sont allés mois et ils sont tannés moi
il restera avec moi les gens de la jsk
et moi et moi on a fabriqué une majorité
régionale qui n'a perdu aucun de ses
élus il ya eu huit composantes ont
pressenti c'est la droite et le centre
la société civile en gros dans lequel il
y avait des marcheurs d'ailleurs comme
monsieur nombreux nageurs il m'a jamais
manqué deux mois ils ont été respectées
ils ont jamais eu aucun problème et
personne ne dit que mon bilan est
dramatique dont qu'ils y ont participé
et comment ils vont faire pour dire
maintenant avec les ministres qu'on n'a
jamais vus ben je trouve que j'ai très
bien ce que je sais la maison commune
des marcheurs schengen qui pour eux à un
mot à mot sur la politique nationale et
et xavier bertrand ce clavier berton il
a eu raison de se déclarer maintenant
pour vous je ne porte pas de jugement je
dis simplement que vous avez bientôt a
décidé d'imprimer son propre calendrier
aviez a dit
ils voient bien qu'il ya une difficulté
pour départager à droite le candidat que
les insectes là dedans il veut jouer sa
propre carte et je vois bien qu'il ya un
risque potentiel qu'ils aient pas
l'élection régionale qui donc sont pas
le club de partage donc il y moins
régional pas régionales si je perds je
souhaite encadrer la présidentielle si
je gagne j'affirme en dehors des partis
en portant une valeur républicaine qui
sort de chez nous quand même plutôt
notre formation
donc il ne se laisse pas imprimer un
calendrier retour dans les environs plus
au compteur
je sais pas s'il aura les régionales je
suis pas si loin en tout cas j'ai
beaucoup je travaille avec lui et j'ai
beaucoup de plaisir dans l'hémicyle fort
aimablement remarquer quand même et je
soulignerai votre attention que les
hauts de france qui n'ont jamais été
dans les gens de france est revenu dans
régions de france le pitch président et
et xavier bertrand est venu et s'y sent
bien
voilà c'est un microbe valérie pécresse
t'emmerder - comme laurent wauquiez
comme carole delga donc moi j'ai cette
capacité à faire en sorte que les gens
se sentent bien autour de moi j'aime
bien ces harmonies la wah diddy si on
voit très bien l'hôtel de ville jean
claude gaudin a occupé pendant 25 ans il
a écrit un livre ses mémoires est ce que
vous avez pris le temps de lire renaud
muselier ce livre non je ne vais pas
acheter méfie vraiment rien à la nes est
assez drôle
savez que j'ai essayé de normaliser les
relations avec jean claude parce que sur
le plan humain nous en passer beaucoup
de choses ensemble
beaucoup de très bonnes quelques-unes
très mauvaise avec une cin exécrable
maintenant il ne fait plus de politique
moi je continue à en faire la vie est
ainsi faite on a vingt ans d'écart et
donc je lui ai souhaité une bonne année
je les vis en fin d'année il m'a envoyé
son livre qui est sur mon bureau avec un
petit mot qui est pour solde de tout
compte avec tous mes voeux de succès
jean-claude dans le texte
le mot de la fin avant de se quitter
grenoble et lyon va regarder les une de
la provence on commence par la provence
vilaine oui alors avec un titre qu'un
jeu de mots un ça plaira renaud muselier
le jeu des 10 bornes
parce qu'on a voulu mesurer on sait que
marseille est une commune qui est très
étendue et on a voulu voir effectivement
c'est en respectant la distance de 10 km
on pouvait aller par exemple au bord de
la mer mais son avis d'un quartier des
cas moins clairement on ne peut pas
aller voir la mer à marseille
confiné au pays d'aider confiné on est
allé à la rencontre des azuréens qui
sont dans les pays bas où les terrasses
ont rouvert ou les restaurants ouverts
qui se dé confine progressivement il
nous raconte cette vie qui reprend la
une de 20 marins terrible coup de gel on
en a parlé le coup de gel notamment dans
les vignes dans le haut var merci
beaucoup merci qui l'amenait clavier
merci denis carreaux et merci pour nos
musées ni s'arrêter
notre avis de l'eic chénard série comme
exactement avait juste bienvenue
regardée comme une sympathique vue
magnifique on remercie nos partenaires
et on remercie le novotel vieux port qui
nous a permis d'avoir un plateau ici est
d'offrir à nos téléspectateurs cette
belle vue sur marseille merci beaucoup
merci encore
d'avoir été notre invité merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis très bon week-end à
tous
[Musique]